[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
berichte und claus kleber
guten abend der hindukusch afghanistan
erscheinen plötzlich wieder
fast so wie vor 20 jahren nach dem
elften september als aus jenen bergen
gesteuerter terror die westliche welt
vor allem ins herz traf wie nie ein
anschlag zuvor nun also der rückzug für
strategen seit jahrtausenden die
schwierigste aller militärischen
unternehmungen dieser abzug aus kabul
gerät quasi live zur täglichen
demütigung der größten militärallianz
der geschichte die bilder sagen alle
nichts wird bleiben was die so genannte
weltgemeinschaft hier versucht hat mit
unsummen von geld unter einsatz und
verlust unzähliger menschen leben die
neuen herren des landes befehlen raus
mit euch und setzen ihre fristen
rückwand über das geschehen heute
im viertelstundentakt heben die
militärmaschine in kabul ab 3.000
menschen hat allein die bundeswehr
bislang ausgeflogen darunter 340
deutsche aber mehr als 100 deutsche
staatsbürger sind noch im land und rund
10.000 ortskräfte die vermutlichen
lebensgefahr schweben durch das
gefährliche chaos an der flughafen mauer
zu gelangen wo weitere tausende
ausharren ist nahezu unmöglich am morgen
kam bei einem schusswechsel ein
afghanischer bewacher des geländes ums
leben alle sind unter druck die zeit
läuft aus überlegungen von us präsident
biden das abzugsdatum 31 august zu
verschieben wie sind die taliban kalt
zurück you can say it loud das ist eine
rote linie bleiben sie länger wäre das
eine verlängerung der besatzung dafür
gibt es keine notwendigkeit wenn sie
länger bleiben wird dass eine reaktion
provozieren
die taliban geben sich vor den kameras
gelassen sie beteuern alles in bester
ordnung tatsächlich wachsen die probleme
militärisch regt sich widerstand gegen
die islamisten im nordöstlichen
pandschir tal die taliban mussten starke
kräfte dort für eine offensive
zusammenziehen und der unmut der
bevölkerung wächst im netz kursieren
videos in denen frauen auf dem land von
hinrichtungen und entführungen junger
mädchen berichten ob das stimmt ist
schwer zu überprüfen aber die berichte
häufen sich die schulen wie hier in
herat sind auch für mädchen geöffnet es
gibt aber nur noch getrennten unterricht
auch an den universitäten werden frauen
und männer getrennt und frauen dürfen
nur noch von weiblichen lehrenden
unterrichtet werden an der grenze zu
pakistan ist unterdessen der
warenverkehr praktisch zum erliegen
gekommen auch hier versuchen tausende
afghanen vor den taliban zu fliehen
das ist kein leben da mal kriegt ein
waffenruhe dann wieder krieg und es gibt
keine arbeit oder zukunft
noch sind die straßen märkte in kabul
voll doch die versorgungskrise vor allem
auf dem land werde sich rasch zuspitzen
befürchten experten das
welternährungsprogramm der vereinten
nationen hatte bislang 14 millionen
afghanen versorgt derzeit kommt nichts
mehr an ungefähr so wenig wie bargeld in
den banken die zentralbank arbeitet
nicht das geld wird knapp
behörden und ministerien sind derweil
zwar bewacht aber die arbeit bleibt
liegen die alte korrupte regierung in
afghanistan ist geschichte eine
überzeugende alternative haben die neuen
machthaber noch nicht
katrin eigendorf über viele jahre unsere
reporterin in afghanistan sammelt ihre
informationen jetzt notgedrungen am
drehkreuz taschkent in usbekistan
kathrin was sagen ihre quellen haben die
taliban jetzt wirklich die kontrolle
über das land
nein das sieht nicht so aus dass sie
wirklich die kontrolle haben sie haben
zwar die macht im land übernommen aber
dieses land zu führen und zu regieren
bedeutet ja viel mehr als nur terror
auszuüben es müssen ja institutionen am
laufen gehalten werden und wir sehen
alleine an der situation am flughafen
dass die taliban die auch nicht mehr
wirklich 100 prozent kontrollieren sie
müssen jetzt im prinzip mit vielen
vielen kräften auch kooperieren um
institutionen am laufen zu halten in
diesem land und das ist das was im
moment was wir im moment aus vielen
quellen in afghanistan hören das große
problem man kooperiert und spricht ja
auch im prinzip mit teilen der alten
kräften zum beispiel mit hamid karsai
dem ersten frei gewählten präsidenten
afghanistans denn im prinzip das angebot
macht dass man versucht eine
versöhnliche
formen des regierens zu finden aber die
taliban sind eben keine bewegung die nur
mit einer stimme spricht sie sind dabei
sich im moment zu finden und wie sehr
die internationale gemeinschaft jetzt
von ihnen abhängig ist zeigt die
tatsache dass die amerikaner und auch
die deutschen ihre evakuierungen gar
nicht ohne sie durchführen können schon
alleine der weg zum flughafen
funktioniert nicht bei den converse ohne
dass taliban diese erlauben oder
evakuieren das zeigt wie die neuen
machtverhältnisse in kabul in
afghanistan aussehen nun ist taliban ja
ein ziemlich
generalisierende begriff da gibt's hier
ein die in dörfern mit gewalt die
scharia durchsetzen und andersdenkende
verfolgen und dann gibt es diejenigen
die in vornehmen hotels in doha und
anderswo mit us und eu diplomaten
verhandeln kann man dann eine linie
erkennen wie dieses afghanistan in der
welt dann unter den taliban auftreten
wird
an diese linie zeichnet sich noch nicht
wirklich ab da gibt es ganz deutliche
grabenkämpfe auch unter den taliban in
afghanistan sprechen die afghanen von
den sogenannten wilden taliban also
denen die wirklich in den dörfern
teilweise terror ausüben und denen die
in dora auftreten das sind ja ganz
andere die im prinzip auf
internationaler bühne mittlerweile mit
diplomaten verhandeln die ja auch die
anerkennung von großen staaten wie zum
beispiel russland mittlerweile genießen
es ist noch nicht klar wer sich wirklich
letztendlich durchsetzen wird ob die ob
die hardliner ein mächtiges wort
mitreden werden ob sich die eher
diplomatischen kräfte durchsetzen werden
sicherlich ist das bestreben der doha
taliban wenn man es mal so sagen kann
nicht wieder zu einem internationalen
paria staat zu werden sondern sich schon
so integrieren also dass afghanistan
irgendwo auch eine rolle in der welt
spielt man ist ja auch abhängig von
internationalen
hilfsmitteln aber wie gesagt das ist
noch nicht entschieden welche fraktionen
künftig in afghanistan die macht
übernehmen wird und wie afghanistan wie
dieses taliban-regime letztendlich
aussehen wird da wird sich noch viel
beweisen dankeschön
allen verantwortlichen ist natürlich
klar dass die bisher 3000 vielleicht
einmal 10.000 menschen die aus
afghanistan heraus geholt werden
wahrscheinlich nicht das ende einer
fluchtbewegung aus afghanistan sein
werden die frage ist was das für
deutschland bedeutet vor allem aus den
reihen der union kam sofort wie ein
reflex aus vielen mündern der satz
2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen
das ist nun bestenfalls eine forderung
eine antwort auf die lage ist es noch
nicht frank buchwald über eine debatte
die eine rolle spielen wird in der
endphase des sogenannten wahlkampfs sie
haben es geschafft menschen aus
afghanistan der hölle von kabul
entkommen es sind hunderte die an diesem
wochenende auf dem amerikanischen
luftwaffenstützpunkt ramstein gelandet
sind
es geht ihnen ganz gut aber sie sehen
erschöpft aus sehr müde wenn man dann
aber sieht wie die kinder wie die
familien hier ankommen mit breitem
lächeln das vaters wird es
eine luftbrücke sie so leben retten so
lange es eben geht dienstag nächster
woche könnte schluss sein drohen die
taliban
außenminister maß aber will auch nach
dem 31 august menschen aus kabul
evakuieren daher arbeiten wir bereits
seit tagen an konkreten schritten um
auch danach noch schutzbedürftigen
afghaninnen und afghanen zu helfen das
land zu verlassen und in sicherheit zu
leben deutschland bereitet sich auf
afghanische flüchtlinge vor manche
bundesländer etwa thüringen planen
eigene aufnahmeprogramme
ministerpräsident ramelow will auf
berlin nicht warten wir erfüllen die
pflichten die alle bundesländer erfüllen
müssen ob dazu ein zusätzliches
hilfsprogramm letztlich noch notwendig
sein wird hängt auch davon ab was die
bundesregierung selber macht solange sie
es nicht erfüllt solange bereiten wir
auch eigene programme vor leben retten
flüchtlingen helfen darin sind bund und
länder einig hessens grüne vize
ministerpräsident al wazir aber setzt
vor allem auch auf solidarität
nachbarstaaten natürlich müssen wir
alles dafür tun dass die länder die vor
allem die afghanen aufnehmen in den
letzten jahrzehnten ja übrigens immer
schon aufgenommen haben wie
beispielsweise pakistan und iran dass
die mit dieser situation nicht alleine
gelassen werden um ortskräfte und ihre
familien allein könne es jedoch nicht
gehen auch andere von den taliban
besonders bedrohte menschen bräuchten
schutz frauen vorne jetzt geht es
zunächst darum die menschen leben von
orts kräften und bedrohten frauen zu
retten da haben wir aus nordrhein
westfalen ein angebot gemacht und ich
werbe dafür ansonsten die un
organisation in der region zu
unterstützen und eine internationale
konferenz zu machen mit usa und kanada
für ein weltweites resettlement programm
in afghanistan gehe es auch um deutsche
selbstverständnis um ein land das für
das richtige stehen und das richtige tun
wollen sagt am abend die
verteidigungsministerin und wagt ein
versprechen unabhängig davon wann die
internationale militärische evakuierungs
operation enden wird werden wir auch
danach weiter alles tun um die
schutzbedürftigen menschen vor ort zu
unterstützen und ihnen zur ausreise aus
afghanistan zu verhelfen der westen
steht im wort auch deutschland noch
starten in ramstein und anderswo
militärtransporter an den hindukusch
retten leben wie lange noch weiß niemand
im rückblick auf
2015 das jahr der grossen flucht wird
gerne vergessen wie schnell auch die
regierung merkel damals mit dem rest
europas auf eine jetzt ist aber gut
politik mit geschlossenen grenzen
umschaltete der unabhängige experte
gerald knaus hatte damals einen plan der
rechte von flüchtlingen geschützt und
die grenzen trotzdem geordnet hätte die
politik hat er an der umsetzung daraus
einen deal mit der türkei gemacht bei
dem flüchtlinge auf der strecke blieben
so war das nicht gedacht
guten abend herr klaus wird sich so was
in diesem jahr wiederholen müssen
guten abend herr kleber es steht hier
tatsächlich unglaublich viel auf dem
spiel die flüchtlingskonvention die 70
jahre gefeiert hat erst vor wenigen
wochen
wird getestet schaffen es diejenigen mit
berechtigter angst vor verfolgung die
definition von jenen denen man helfen
sollte überhaupt aus dem land heraus die
taliban kontrollieren die grenzen die
nachbarn haben gesagt sie werden die
grenzen schließen die türkei hat ihre
grenzen geschlossen die echte gefahr die
echte herausforderung ist dass diese
menschen die schutz brauchen gar nicht
herauskommen nun gibt es ja viele die
die taliban fürchten müssen die
unbedingt aber es um leben und tod geht
irgendwo hin wollen das wird mich
erschöpft seien mit noch drei vier tagen
luftbrücke aus kabul wo könnten wo
sollten wo werden diese menschen am ende
hin gehen also ich fand sehr ermutigend
in ihrem beitrag die wortmeldungen der
verteidigungsministerin denn tatsächlich
muss es darum gehen auch über das ende
der evakuierungen hinaus darauf zu
drängen dass menschen die den alliierten
geholfen haben die aber auch aus anderen
gründen gefährdet sind richterinnen
historiker die zu den taliban geforscht
haben künstler alle die die an einem
afghanistan gearbeitet haben dass die
taliban hassen die müssen angst haben
und die sollten wir weiterhin versuchen
herauszuholen und das wird
wahrscheinlich nur gehen entweder indem
wir mit den taliban die taliban daran
erinnern dass sie ausreisen lassen das
ging damals mit dem kommunistischen
vietnam auch für einige hunderttausend
die wir durften ausreisen oder indem wir
den nachbarländern signalisieren last
menschen herein wir helfen euch
finanziell aber eben auch durch aufnahme
hat europa da es ist immer schwierig
menschenrechte miteinander zu
vergleichen weil sie alle im grunde und
teilbar sind aber ist europas
verantwortung für die menschen in
afghanistan noch ein stück größer als
zum beispiel die verantwortung für
menschen in syrien weil in afghanistan
ja westliches handeln ganz wesentlich
die geschehene zu beeinflusst haben also
ich glaube nach 20 jahren präsenz aber
auch den ganzen menschlichen kontakten
die wir dort hatten aber auch der dem
versprechen an afghanen sich heraus zu
wagen sich auszusprechen für ein ein
anderes modell der gesellschaft die
haben risiken sind risiken eingegangen
haben wir eine verantwortung für diese
menschen ich glaube aber auch und das
ist positiv dass sehr viele in
deutschland das auch empfinden
afghanistan ist sehr weit weg aber durch
die afghanen die schon hier sind und
durch alle die die zeit in afghanistan
verbracht haben gibt es und ich sehe
dass in den letzten tagen wieder doch
eine breite unterstützung für das was er
jetzt zum glück in den letzten tagen
viele politiker auch vorgeschlagen haben
schutzbedürftige herauszuholen da hat
sebastian kurz der kanzler von
österreich wieder deutlichere worte
gefunden als deutscher politiker im
moment finden er hat gesagt er will
deshalb keine afghanen ins land lassen
und zwar überhaupt keine weil er nicht
wolle dass die taliban ideologie
importiert werde diese haltung ist
glaube ich auch nicht ganz exklusiv
österreichisch also um ganz klar zu
sagen das ist ungefähr so wie wenn man
jene die aus dem aus dem kommunistischen
ländern über den eisernen vorhang oder
über die berliner mauer fliehen konnten
zurückschicken will weil sie den
kommunismus
weil man gerade im kommunismus
importieren würde diese menschen um die
es jetzt geht über die wir sprechen sind
ja genau die die taliban hassen die vor
den taliban flüchten und die
vergleichbare situation wäre die
situation der juden in österreich nach
dem anschluss nicht jeder der stadt
wollte fliehen aber es gab menschen die
wahren existenzieller gefahr und so
gesehen ist es wichtig dass wir auch an
dem tragen die lichter ausgehen am
flughafen in kabul wenn die westlichen
flugzeuge nicht mehr fliegen können dass
wir dann auf diese menschen nicht
vergessen der appell des migrations
forschers danke schön herr klaus dank
ihnen
mitten in der urlaubszeit müssen viele
bahnreisende umdisponieren steht hier
bist du es machst du die nachrichten das
ist ich wollte aber ein ganz anderes
thema der nachrichten es geht natürlich
um den warnstreik denn seit dem frühen
morgen wir streiken die lokführer nun
auch den personenverkehr wieder laut
bahn fielen rund 70 prozent der normalen
zutaten aus den rest hielt der konzern
mit einem notfallplan auf recht zwischen
großen städten setzte er busse ein die
angebotene corona prämie wie es gdl chef
weselsky zurück im zdf kritisierte er
dass die bahn keine summe nannte
immigration streit mit belarus will
polen nun einen zweieinhalb meter hohen
grenzzaun bauen außerdem sollen mehr
soldaten liegen zu sichern bei dem
streit geht es um tausende migranten die
seit wochen illegal ins land kommen es
gibt den verdacht dass belarus die
menschen gezielt aus dem nahen osten
einfliegt und in seine nachbarländer
schickt als vergeltung für eu-sanktionen
gleich zwei heftige unwetter haben die
usa getroffen mit gewaltigen regenmengen
besonders heftig war es im bundesstaat
tennessee wo teilweise mehr als 400
liter pro quadratmeter runter kamen und
ganze häuser weggerissen mindestens 21
bewohner starben in den fluten etliche
weitere werden vermisst
glimpflicher als erwartet kamen die
menschen an der ostküste davon bevor
hurrikan auf land traf hatte er sich zum
tropensturm abgeschwächt trotzdem
verursachte er sturzfluten und
stromausfälle
im kampf gegen kinderarmut fordern mehr
als 20 sozialverbände und gewerkschaften
radikale reformen sie plädieren für eine
kindergrundsicherung die die bestehenden
leistungen bündelt und ersetzt und
möglichst automatisch ausgezahlt wird
als basis müsse das existenzminimum neu
und realistisch berechnet werden
ursprünglich wollte die große koalition
das pflegegeld der höhe für betroffene
die zu so versorgt werden doch das wurde
dann doch nicht umgesetzt
nun will der sozialverband vdk die
erhöhung einklagen hintergrund ist eine
studie die zeigt wie verheerend sich die
korona pandemie ausgewirkt hat demnach
fühlten sich 70 prozent der
pflegebedürftigen und ihre angehörigen
psychisch schwer belastet die
allermeisten jeden den kontakt zu
dritten und fast jeder dritte
pflegebedürftige verließ die eigene
wohnung gar nicht mehr
es ist völlig normal die nase allmählich
voll zu haben von incidents der zahl
positiv auf corinna getesteter auf
100000 menschen gerechnet nüchtern
betrachtet ist das statistisch gefühlt
seit anderthalb jahren taktgeber des
lebens öffentlich und privat die macht
die türen öffnet oder schließt zu
freunden zu kultur zu feiern schulen
kaufhäusern reisen kurz zur freiheit
noch liegt die zahl insgesamt bei werten
die man sich in den schlimmsten zeiten
der pandemie noch gewünscht hätte aber
doch schon wieder sind es deutlich mehr
als 50 neue fälle auf 100000 vor allem
ist der trend der neuinfektionen
eindeutig die entwicklung ist
unterschiedlich weit fortgeschritten nrw
ist ein schwerpunkt leverkusen die erste
stadt die wieder über 200 liegt und
trotzdem ist das ein bild das man heute
mit praktisch 60 prozent vollständig
geimpften sicher anders betrachten kann
als vor einem jahr als es noch keinerlei
impfungen gab die frage ist nur wie
anders diese frage ist umstritten
politisch aufgeladen im wahlkampf
christiane hütter bericht seit
anderthalb jahren starren wir auf diese
kurve von ihr hängt ab was geht und was
nicht geht in diesem land bei einer
stabilen sieben tage incidents über
einer inzidenz von über 100 dass wir
jetzt runterkommt mit unseren instanzen
ohne incidents geht's nicht und
plötzlich geht es doch die 100 die 35
die 50 das soll bald schon egal sein der
bundesgesundheitsminister räumt die
zahlen heute persönlich ab die 50er
incidents im gesetz die hat ausgedient
die galt für eine ungeimpfte bevölkerung
wir haben mittlerweile ja auch viele
menschen die sich haben impfen lassen
und deswegen ist mein vorschlag jetzt
auch diesen maßstab diese 50er incident
aus dem gesetz zügig zu streichen das
passt nicht mehr in corona kabinett sind
sie sich einig die lage hat sich
verändert eine 50er inzidenz heute ist
nicht mehr vergleichbar mit der von vor
einem jahr haben heute eine völlig
veränderte situation wir haben eine
impfquote wir haben ein
gesundheitssystem das den
herausforderungen standhält und deswegen
wird es zeit immer dann wenn
einschränkungen erforderlich dies sind
diese nicht nur am infektionsgeschehen
sondern auch an der hospitalisierung und
an der impfquote auszurichten künftig
also soll die krankenhausleistungen das
maß aller dinge sein aktuell liegt die
hospitalisierung rat der bundesweit bei
1,3 auf 100.000 einwohner
doch sie steigt ob und ab welchem wert
neue maßnahmen ergriffen werden müssen
soll nicht mehr in berlin entschieden
werden sondern in den ländern die
inzidenz wird immer ein parameter seien
der irgendwo mit schwingen wird den man
auch weiter an sieht vielleicht auch die
instanz der geimpften der ungeimpften
die inzidenz verschiedener
altersschichten aber ich glaube wir
brauchen einen neuen leitwert und dass
wir jetzt das thema der krankenhaus
belegung mit einbeziehen als light wird
halt die schon für richtig oberarzt
tätig aber will nicht auf den
frühwarnindikatoren stents verzichten er
nimmt auf seiner isolierstation in
darmstadt wieder vermehrt schwerkranke
auf im schnitt jünger und zu 80%
ungeimpft der lungenarzt braucht die
zwei wochen vorlauf die er durch den
blick auf die inzidenz gewinnt wenn wir
einfach anfangen würden nur unsere
vorbereitung nach der
spezialisierungsgrad zu machen dann
würden wir unsere aufnahmen cupid
aufnahmen pro tag zählen und dann erst
mit unserer personal und räumlichen
planung beginnen das funktioniert nicht
so kurzfristig können wir im krankenhaus
in der pandemie zumindest nicht arbeiten
kritiker halten die abkehr von der
inzidenz für ein reines wahlkampfmanöver
die instanzen einfach aus dem gesetz zu
streichen anstelle sie um weitere
faktoren zu ergänzen ist die völlig
falsche lösung und deutet eher darauf
hin dass man unpopuläre entscheidung vor
der wahl vermeiden will anstelle
wirkliches krisen-management
voranzubringen ein echter kurswechsel
steht bevor weg von der inzidenz schon
am mittwoch soll sich der bundestag
damit befassen
ein ähnliches thema an einem anderen
ende der welt die olympischen spiele in
tokio während letztes jahr fällig
gewesen wegen corona wurden sie schweren
herzens auf dieses jahr verschoben sie
sind der gefahr damit aber nicht
entronnen das virus erwies sich als
langstreckenläufer und war weiter
dynamisch unterwegs und wurde dann noch
von olympia angefeuert auch ohne
zuschauer im stadion die menschen japans
haben die chance dankbar ergriffen sich
an den spielen mal zu freuen spontan
privat oder auf der straße mit freunden
das hat dem virus schon gereicht die
paralympics starten jetzt einen monat
später in einer aufsteigenden pandemie
kurve in japan stefanie schöne baum
berichtet
der patient wurde bereits von drei
krankenhäusern abgelehnt und das husten
hat vor einer woche begonnen
eine corona klinik in kawasaki das delta
virus breitet sich in japan immer mehr
aus der patient hat probleme beim atmen
braucht sauerstoff der arzt hat uns
angewiesen ihn aufzunehmen
die intensivstation ist voll
sie wissen nicht mehr wohin mit dem chor
wird patienten
wer nicht künstlich beatmet werden muss
kann nicht mehr auf dieser station
bleiben
shefki kuqi thani läutet die
intensivstation in der wichtigsten
klinik von kawasaki der nachbarstadt
tokios es ist die einzige klinik der
stadt die patienten mit herz lungen
versagen aufnehmen kann jetzt aber
reicht der platz nicht mehr zu
beginn der olympischen spiele haben wir
auch noch patienten aus tokio aufnehmen
können aber seit dem zehnten august
steigen die zahlen einfach immer weiter
die abschottung der athleten die leeren
zuschauer rängen während der olympischen
spiele hat funktioniert für die sportler
und delegation nicht aber für die bürger
tokios viele wollten die spiele
gemeinsam sehen passten nicht mehr auf
steckten sich an das land befindet sich
im ausnahmezustand
mittlerweile gibt es mehr als 22.000
neuinfektionen am tag das
gesundheitssystem ist bereits über dem
limit die regierung hat angeordnet dass
menschen mit leichten und mittleren
symptom nicht mehr ins krankenhaus gehen
sollen
luigi suzuki ist arzt in tokio und
behandelt corona patienten zu hause
wenn es jeden tag mehr patienten werden
kann ich meinen job als arzt nicht mehr
machen
die ärzte versuchen alles doch reicht
die versorgung bei corona patienten
meist nicht aus bei vielen
verschlechtert sich der zustand zu hause
doch ins krankenhaus kommen sie erst
wenn sie fast im sterben liegen und dann
gibt es meistens keine betten mehr das
größte problem ist die welle der
ungeimpften das sind die schwersten
fälle
wenn wir noch einen patienten an die
herz-lungen-maschine anschließen müssen
haben wir keinen platz mehr so
katastrophal ist die situation
die worte des arztes überschlagen sich
fast seine verzweiflung ist beklemmend
bei keine besserung in sicht scheint die
paralympics beginnen morgen und die
zahlen werden sicherlich weiter steigen
wir bleiben beim thema corona in den usa
hat die arzneimittelbehörde den
impfstoff von beyond inc pfizer nun
vollständig zugelassen bislang gab es
dort nur eine notfall genehmigung laut
us experten könnte die impfkampagnen und
neuen schwung erfahren denn viele die
noch nicht geimpft sind nannten als
grund für ihr zögern die noch fehlende
komplett zulassung
autoelektronik spielekonsolen smart home
produkte kaum ein technisches gerät
kommt heute noch ohne halbleiter aus
entsprechend dramatisch wirken sich die
aktuellen lieferengpässe aus bosch
produziert die chips seit kurzem selbst
und das nicht irgendwo sondern an einem
wort der sich inzwischen den namen
silicon saxony verdient hat frank
bethmann richtig wir reden über dresden
ein ort der über frauenkirche und
christstollen hinaus längst auch für
moderne mikroelektronik für hightech
bekannt ist dresden gilt inzwischen als
der fünftgrößte halbleiter oder ship
produktionsstandort der welt auch
deswegen besuchte bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier heute das neue werk
von bosch ein weiterer großer akteur der
chipindustrie der seit kurzem im silicon
saxony ansässig ist in dresden
produzieren bereits jetzt vier der
großen chiphersteller und sind motor für
eine ganze region
silicon saxony das heißt in zahlen
mittlerweile über 70.000 beschäftigte
2500 firmen darunter viele start-ups die
zusammen mehr als 16 milliarden euro
umsatz jährlich machen und es geht
weiter mikrochips sind nachgefragt mini
auch weil internationale lieferketten
durch corona unterbrochen worden ein
wermutstropfen aber bleibt wichtige
entscheidungen werden noch immer
woanders getroffen im ausland oder im
westen der republik dort wo die großen
ihre konzernzentralen haben in sachsen
setzt man auf die vielen kleinen
startups eines tages so hoffen sie
entsteht dort ein goliath der dann auch
in den dax aufrücken könnte tatsächlich
hat es nämlich bis heute noch kein
einziges ostdeutsches unternehmen in die
erste börsenliga geschafft dank an den
börse frank ja dorthin hat es der
immobilienriese von movea geschafft und
er hat einen weiteren versuch gestartet
die deutsche wohnen zu übernehmen er
bietet aktionären nun 53 euro pro
anteilsschein einen euro mehr als beim
letzten mal damals kam von oh wir nicht
über die nötigen 50 prozent
zusammengehören den beiden
immobilienriesen
550.000 wohnungen im wert von mehr als
80 milliarden euro
vor genau 75 jahren gründete die
britische besatzungsmacht in deutschland
ein neues bundesland es wurde das
bevölkerungsreichste und bekam den namen
nordrhein westfalen für nrw ein guter
grund zum feiern mit prominenten gästen
darunter bundeskanzlerin merkel und
ministerpräsident laschet er sprach in
einem land das zusammenhalt lebe was ich
zuletzt bei der flutkatastrophe gezeigt
habe ein höhepunkt ist diese lichter
show die zur stunde den düsseldorfer
landtag zur bunten kulisse macht
in sachen bund kann da noch ein bisschen
was kommen würde lauf des abends das zdf
versucht es jetzt bei ihnen mit
hochspannung fiktion und realen
nachrichten dann wieder um kurz vor
mitternacht mit
[Musik]
guten abend nach dem tief manfred kommt
das neue hoch gaia das allerdings bringt
sehr kühle luft mit denn die strömung
kommt eindeutig aus nördlichen aus
nordöstlichen richtungen aber so ein
hoch hat ja immer zwei seiten zum einen
die kalte ostseite aber auch eine warme
westseite und das führt dazu dass in den
nächsten tagen hier auf island durchaus
wärmerekorde fast zu erwarten sind das
heißt temperaturen von durchaus 20 grad
dass es da oben sehr ungewöhnlich sie
sehen dass an dieser orange farbe da ist
es dann wirklich wärmer als bei uns in
mitteleuropa
heute nacht fällt etwas regen hier in
der oberlausitz oder auch am alpenrand
aber im westen damit es klar und da wird
es dann auch richtig kalt zwischen
nordfriesland und der eifel sinken die
werte auf 9 bis 7 grad an der nordsee
bleibt es milder da wären noch das
wasser und auch unter den regenwolken
bleibt es etwas milder da sie die
temperaturen auf zweistellige 14 bis 10
grad und morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen meist bei 19 bis 23
grad nur in bayern wird es noch kühler
bleiben mit 14 bis 17 grad und das sind
ja höchsttemperaturen dh die meiste zeit
des tages ist es noch kälter denn dort
tut sich die sonne morgen wirklich
schwer in bayern da fällt auch noch
etwas regen sonst wäre das ein sehr
freundlicher dienstag und in den
nächsten tagen geht es zum teil mit
sonne weiter aber da wird es von tag zu
tag älter und am freitag liegen die
höchsttemperaturen nur noch bei 14 bis
19 grad guten abend